esos dos círculos no son del mismo
tamaño lo que quiero que hagan entonces
en este momento es que decidan cuál de
los dos círculos es más grande que el
otro quieren atrás que levanten la mano
los que creen que el círculo azul es más
grande que el rojo
una gran parte quiere que el círculo
rojo es en realidad manuel azul no son
pocos
antes de que diera cualquier cosa son
dos círculos cuál fue su primer
pensamiento juego es un cinto
que los círculos eran iguales cierto y
la razón por la cual es porque se ven
iguales ahora yo les digo que los
círculos son exactamente iguales y que
esa es la razón por la cual se ven
iguales
exacto los acabo de engañar les mentí
todos me creyeron así primer experimento
son experimentos que sacado de facebook
famosos de cuento algunos desconocen
segundo experimento
por favor quien vea este vestido negro y
azul
están absolutamente locos de que el
color es bendecido
blanco y dorado yo sin duda lo blanco y
dorado no entiendo cómo existe gente que
ve el vestido negro azul en según donde
ven el negro
no tiene sentido no tiene sentido
lastimosamente
lastimosamente he visto otras fotos del
recibe el vestido es en efecto negro de
azul aunque hagamos creo que una mayoría
que lo vemos blanco y dorado entonces
tenemos 22 experimentos dos escenarios
dos cosas interesantes una en la que les
digo algo
en la que ustedes me creen de una que es
mentira y no solamente me creen sino que
intentan decir cuál es más grande que el
otro cuál de los círculos más grandes
que piensan
alrededor de la mentira y un segundo
escenario en el que les muestro algo que
por más de que yo les diga que es de un
color negro de azul
ustedes den otro blanco y dorada
tenemos otros escenarios muy muy
interesantes que entonces nos ponen nos
ponen a pensar mucho
no importa que tan claro les diga yo que
sé de sigue es en realidad negre azul
los que lo ven blanco y ahora van a
seguir creyendo que el blanco y dorado
entre dos semanas cuando lo vean no van
a estar seguros si es en efecto dorado
lo interesante y lo que les quiero
hablar hoy es que esto está pasando en
las aulas de clase esto está pasando con
todos estudiantes niños en los colegios
jóvenes en las universidades estamos los
profesores intentando decir todo de la
forma más clara posible incluso los
buenos profesores son los humanos que
nos sentimos que decimos las cosas
claras que hacemos la presentación clara
o que escribimos viene del tablero de
forma organizada y los estudiantes no
están entendiendo otra cosa o dos no les
importa
entonces sucede que creemos que entre
más claro digamos las cosas
más va a ser mejor mejor va a ser el
entorno de aprendizaje del estudiante
dónde está el error round no no entre
más cosas entre más claras sean las
presentaciones mejor va a aprender el
estudiante y ojo no lo digo yo lo dicen
estudios que dicen cosas por ejemplo
como el estilo de las creencias
cualitativas y de sentido común
iniciales del estudiante sobre un
ejemplo particular el movimiento y las
causas tienen un gran efecto sobre el
rendimiento en física pero la
instrucción convencional induce un solo
induce sólo un pequeño cambio en esas
creencias esto digamos que es un estudio
particular de la enseñanza de la física
pero a mí me gusta decir qué pasa en la
mayoría de las disciplinas
creemos que entre más claro digamos las
cosas van a aprender al estudiante
cuando hay pruebas
de que esas presentaciones claras
inducen pequeño camión esas creencias
entonces la pregunta es listo qué
podemos hacer al respecto
como se ve un ejemplo de esto por
ejemplo en las aulas está el profesor
hablando del vestido diciendo que
claramente es negro y azul porque él lo
ve en negro y azul
el estudiante a las 11 de la mañana con
hambre y con ganas de almorzar porque no
comieron nada porque no alcanzó a
desayunar probablemente escuché que es
negro azul aunque lo voy a blanco y
dorado y digan eso sí ok es negro pero
en dos semanas cuando le pregunté en el
examen de qué color del vestido él va a
decir que blanco y dorado porque así lo
ve por mate que hubiéramos dicho que no
el profesor los profesores seguimos
creyendo que entre más claro digamos las
cosas mejor va a ser el entorno de
aprendizaje y cada vez es más claro que
no en particular
hay una persona a la cual admiro mucho
del xxi blair reconocido por su canal de
youtube veritas john que hizo su tesis
doctoral en física en cómo realizar
vidas de youtube para enseñar ciencias y
doctorado en eso entonces es increíble
en su estudio y en varios artículos que
publicaba con su con su asesora de grado
se dieron cuenta de algo que me parece
muy interesante y es
en una presentación en ningún momento el
alumno es consciente de que lo que está
percibiendo está en desacuerdo con lo
que se le está presentando para mí esto
fue con el play from una cosa súper
bacanal a cualquier me di cuenta que yo
no sabía porque yo era los que creía que
entre más claro fuera mejor aprendía los
estudiantes pero resulta que es que el
estudiante nunca está poniendo en
contradicción lo que se le está
enseñando con lo que ya sabe del mundo
si digamos por ejemplo una típica clase
de física se le dice al estudiante en un
entorno sin aire sin resistencia al aire
gustando un piano como una manzana caen
al mismo tiempo y el estudiante dice ok
si yo yo le quiero al profesor el
profesor es el que sabe digamos que sí
es verdad pero entonces resulta que en
ningún momento el estudiante está
poniendo a prueba eso con lo que dice su
intuición su intuición obviamente le va
a decir que sin piano está cayendo hacia
él se tiene que quitar cierto mientras
que una manzana digamos que se quitará
pero no se quitará con tanto susto luego
su intuición así como la intuición es de
qué sirve
de circulación de igual tamaño le va a
decir que el piano caerá más rápido por
más de quien casi no hubieran dicho que
no
resulta entonces que esta misma gente
del doctorado de cómo hacer vídeos
chéveres para parar para enseñar ciencia
dice que si exponemos a los estudiantes
a conceptos erróneos comunes como por
ejemplo ese incluso el entorno
interactivo puede ayudarle a superar
estas dificultades como quien dice
dijimos de dictar tema dijimos de decir
las cosas claras
más bien digamos las cosas que no son
claras para que el cliente active
lo que se le está enseñando con lo que
entiende del mundo
preguntémosle al estudiante aquí colores
del vestido
preguntémosle porque quiere el
estudiante que el vestido de un color y
nosotros lo vemos de otro dejemos de
dictar clases de la forma más clara
posible digamos
si hay profesoras y si algún profesor
está viendo este vídeo sabe que esto ya
es verdad los profesores ya tienen esto
más claro que nunca y sin embargo es muy
difícil hacer un cambio al respecto
ellos dicen el sistema educativo ya está
establecido es muy difícil hacer algo
distinto es muy difícil cambiarlo porque
porque tenemos cierto cronograma de
actividades que tenemos que cumplir
porque los estudiantes tienen que
presentar ciertas exámenes para
demostrar si se aprendieron o si se
apropiaron o 900 conocimientos porque
hay que avanzar al ritmo que está
dispuesto en el cronograma entonces
dicen cómo voy a cambiar algo si el
sistema está así nos hemos dedicado
entonces mucho a criticar el sistema
pero pocos pocos proponen una solución
por ejemplo
los teléfonos hace 150 años eran las
máquinas grandes complicadas y costosas
de usar vivendi a los teléfonos una cosa
lo más simple y barata de usar no son
baratos para ser barato de usar en los
carros los carros antes eran carros a
jalados por caballos y vendían los
carros como los conocemos no tienen nada
que ver con eso y sin embargo hace 150
años las aulas era la educación
consistía en un aula de 20 niños alzando
la mano para preguntar o decir algo y
hoy en día la educación consiste en un
aula de 30 ó 40 años en la misma aula
levantando la mano para preguntar o
decir algo entonces digamos que lo que
voy a
a proponer no es una solución un cambio
al sistema educativo lo que voy a
proponer en este momento es un
una opción para los profesores dentro
del sistema educativo difícil de cambiar
para que empiece a cambiar para hacer
algo al respecto para que los
estudiantes en el mundo ha progresado y
que queremos queremos estudiantes
creativos innovadores e independientes
críticos con habilidad de conectar cosas
no queremos estudiantes que simplemente
sea con matemáticas y físicas queremos
estudiantes que que se expongan tanto a
las matemáticas como al arte y como a la
danza entonces lo que voy a proponer es
una forma una forma en la que de pronto
podemos encaminarnos más ágil
a motivar a estudiantes de hacer es ese
crítico independiente creativo con la
habilidad de conectar que necesitamos
sino simplemente una persona que sepa
cuál es el trinomio cuadrado perfecto
encontrado que la investigación que hice
con el profesor joel su lugar en la
universidad antioquia de tres semestres
con un grupo de física de primeros
semestres en el que proponemos tres
cosas esenciales tres ponencias dentro
del sistema educativo que tenemos hoy en
día primera cosa esencial ya se la dije
no dictar más clase el profesor debe
dejar de ser el protagonista de la clase
el protagonista de un aula de clase es
el estudiante son los estudiantes
digamos que
es muy difícil es muy difícil pero pero
se ha demostrado en una metodología que
se llama instrucción o instrucción entre
iguales instrucción entre pares que si
se hace al estudiante un par más
incrementa el dominio del estudiante
tanto el razonamiento conceptual como de
la resolución cuantitativa de problemas
en esta metodología propone un
aprendizaje colectivo entre estudiantes
en donde con algunas lecturas previas y
discusiones en la clase el estudiante
aprende más y además dice
participa más en la clase y gane que
profesor no quiere que los estudiantes
participan más
hay varios profesores que no quisieran
eso los profesores digamos modernos que
queremos generar el cambio quisiéramos
que los estantes participen más pero nos
cuesta mucho lograr que los estudiantes
participen más y entonces la cca viene
bien en nuestro segundo elemento
esencial de la metodología y es cómo
hacer para meditar que ha de saber como
si no vamos a dictar clase entonces cómo
hacer para abordar los temas que son
necesarias abordar durante durante el
periodo en el que se tiene acordada
nuestra propuesta es una lectura previa
a la clase
recuerdan esa época en la que no existía
la imprenta y era imposible reproducir
un montón de libros para todos los que
estaban en el salón no porque porque
saber por qué ofrece mucho tiempo si
recuerdan y sabe porque en la que el
acceso a la información era muy difícil
y no había ni siquiera internet para
acceder a ella tal vez sí porque hay
unos dígitos por acá pero pero la
mayoría los niños y los jóvenes de hoy
no recuerdan esa época porque no les
tocó el acceso a la información está
allí recuerden debemos como profesor en
dejar de ser protagonistas y a ser
protagonista al estudiante hacerlo un
par dejar que él acceda a la información
y llegar al aula que hace a discutir esa
información en la que accedió los
profesores que están acá lo que están
viendo probablemente dirán cómo se
siente no le es imposible lograr hacerlo
leer y ahí es el medio dijo
no el estudio el profesor debe dejar de
ser ese de hace 150 años en el que tenía
que decirles la información los
estudiantes por la época en la que
estaba y debe ser el ahora el que
promueva a los estudiantes a buscar esa
información como motivamos entonces a
los estudiantes a hacer una lectura
previa de la clase pues como les digo no
si intentando cambiar la educación
dentro del sistema dentro del sistema
teniendo cambia la educación pero el
sistema es muy difícil de cambiar dentro
del sistema está la evaluación está el
hacer exámenes hagamos los exámenes
sobre las lecturas hagamos unos quiz
scada que hace sobre la lectura que
tuvieron que leer no pongamos a leer
cosas horribles no hagamos a los
estudiantes sentirse así la idea no es
con la lectura y maltratar al estudiante
si la idea es
el estudiante se motive a leer para
para discutir en clase hagamos las
cruces sencillos no les preguntemos
cosas difíciles sobre la lectura si la
lectura decía que una app que la masa de
un carro era una tonelada preguntémosles
en el quiz de la clase cuadra más en un
carro o instituto no por la masa y 35 en
la macarena la masa de medio claro no
les permite unas presencias que los
motiven que los que les dan a entender
que la lectura que están haciendo se ve
reflejada en un resultado sí
hagámosles
preguntas sencillas no estoy diciendo
que bajemos el nivel y en esto entonces
entrar a la tercera parte de la
propuesta que nosotros hacemos es el
elemento de la predictibilidad porque
estamos los profesores tan obstinados la
que los estudiantes sepan qué es lo que
se les va a preguntar porque los
profesores guardamos con tanto recelo el
examen que vamos a hacer los estudiantes
porque no mostrárselos desde antes por
qué no decirles exactamente lo que hacen
el examen es el examen un momento
realmente para pensar y hacer una
construcción cognitiva en el cerebro de
cómo se resuelve un problema cómo o cómo
pasó algo en el momento de la historia
cómo o cómo se entiende una ley pues el
momento del examen simplemente para
poner a prueba
esos procesos que ya fueron dados en las
sesiones de discusión
dejemos de sentir que el que el
estudiante no no debe ganar como creer
como a como seguir siendo el
protagonista de la clase
si involucramos a los estudiantes en un
entorno de predictibilidad los
estudiantes van a ser mucho más
motivados a estudiar por lo menos hemos
mostrado con nuestro curso y eso
queremos motivarlos a que los otros
profesores hagan voy a hacer un
experimento sencillo en el que en el que
quiero que hagan conmigo lo que yo voy a
hacer en primer lugar con su mano
derecha por favor hagan esto en su pecho
o en su mano en su pierna si quiere si
conmigo
esto 1234 mundo está en el 3
quiero que con su mano izquierda también
golpe en su otra pierna 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
hasta ahí todo bien
digamos que eso lo que les ha bajado que
sientes a leer
algunos parece imagínense algunos son
capaces ahora quiero que sigan haciendo
eso pero solamente miren en el 1 y en el
bus con la pierna derecha sin dejar de
hacer eso haga lo siguiente 3 4 1 2
perdón
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 quien es capaz
dejar de hacer para la mano derecha
algunos pero tienen que la mayoría no
digamos que entonces el primer 1-2-3-4
lo que ponemos a leer digamos que el
1234 del ejercicio que pongamos en la
lectura y la mayoría de los profesores
que están haciendo el examen exponiendo
el estudiante hacer algo de este estilo
ah
tiene sentido de música sabe que no
tiene sentido carlos desde antes
entonces hagamos eso también en las
clases de historia de geografía de
ciencias de biología de física de
matemáticas de ética y filosofía por qué
no por qué por qué no poner al cliente
en un entorno de predictibilidad mismo
que nuestro método ya tenía 33 elementos
pero va a mencionar un tercer elemento
un cuarto elemento pero que lo mencionó
como 3a porque es un elemento opcional
que sé que muchos profesores no les va a
gustar y es permitamos de los
estudiantes a repetir exámenes no el
mismo para repetir un examen que evalúen
los mismos conocimientos
porque no no es un objetivo de la
educación que el estudiante aprenda
mejor a lo largo del tiempo en discurso
porque no queremos que los estudiantes
repitan porque más trabajo para el
profesorado porque hay que calificar más
porque es muy difícil si yo entiendo
pero
cuando hicimos este experimento la
universidad ya que nos dimos cuenta que
de todos los que perdían el 50% de las
personas que repetían
aprobaban es decir mejoraban y no era el
mismo examen era completamente punto
distinto es que evalúan los mismos
conocimientos
nuestra propulsión entonces qué
estos tres cuatro elementos básicos que
están acorde al sistema educativo como
lo tenemos hoy en día tal vez puedan
motivar más a los estudiantes a ser más
creativos más independientes más
críticos ya conectar más elementos
algunos planes y los estaba repitiendo
exámenes les iba mejor pero recuerden
que además estaban siendo autodidactas
estaban aprendiendo a leer un texto
científico por su cuenta y estaban
aprendiendo estudiar ya mejorar para los
exámenes entonces por qué no porque es
más agua para el profesor si se
estructura de forma correcta de pronto
no de más trabajo para el profesor lo
último con lo que quiera terminar que
digamos es la base que nos motivó a
construir este proyecto es esta frase de
carl sagan de su libro 'los dragones'
del en el por regla general las
sociedades humanas no son innovadoras
sino más bien jerárquicas y ritualistas
cualquier sugerencia de cambio se acoge
con recelo ya que implica la incómoda
transformación futura del ritual y la
jerarquía imperantes es decir la
situación de una serie de rituales por
otra o tal vez por una sociedad menos
estructurada y regida por un número
inferior de rituales sin embargo llega
un momento en que es preciso que las
sociedades cambien los dogmas del pasado
tranquilos son insuficientes para un
presente tumultuoso aseveró hablan
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]